>> PETERSON: Hi, everyone. Welcome to the
Wave Federation talk. I'm talking about what
we're doing with Wave Federation in open source.
I'm Dan Peterson, product manager on the Wave
APIs and the Federation open source effort.
With me is also is Jochen Beckmann, who's
the tech lead for the Federation effort as
well as J.D. Zamfirescu, who is the lead on
the open source efforts. So today, we'll go
ahead and jump in to agenda slide. Fairly
short for the agenda, I'll kick things off
explaining what Wave Federation is and where
it's headed. And then, we'll do a bit of a
tag team between Jochen and J.D. diving a
lot deeper into the architecture, the model,
becoming an open source and how things like
FedOne works. And we'll explain all that in
a moment. So, you know, at a very high level
for context, Google Wave is a new communication
and collaboration tool. And the whole point
is to help people get, help people get things
done. And beyond the product, there is the,
the rich API platform and then the federation
protocol. You may have heard us talk about
this as the three Ps, the Product Platform
Protocol of Google Wave. And this talk is
primarily about the protocol. We're also lucky
to have Rob Horne from SAP and David LaPalomento
from Novell here to help do some demos a little
bit later. And we'll so some interesting demos
I hope you'll like. But by the end of the
talk, you'll understand how Wave Federation
itself works. As well as how to get up and
running with your own, with FedOne, which
is really how to run your own Wave service.
Understand more about the code of open source
to date. And really just generally where things
are headed with the, this community and some
client-server work we're doing and things
of that nature. So, at the high level, this
protocol presents a great opportunity for
communication and collaboration across the
Web to really get improved. So it's not just
talking about, you know, making things work
better in one product. The whole idea is that
to use common protocols and open source technology
so that you can actually build a distributed
network of Wave providers. Notice, there is
no central server in that diagram, and that's
the whole point. So, today I don't know who
saw that the epiphany video about, you know,
what is Google Wave before but mainstream
collaboration is really dominated by email.
And that's all right. It clearly it works.
It's very popular. But what you, what we've
often noticed is that information is ripped
from its context and put in the email. And
that's--and then it's transfer over the wire
and that sort of a lousy format. And it seems
like given things like broadband, HTML5, and
other advances in computing, we can do better.
And so, that's where sort of Wave Federation
enters the picture. The idea is let users
use the system that works best for them. And
just let sort of collaboration flourish in
that way. There are clearly some pieces that
are inherent to Google Wave the product as
opposed to sort of the Wave Federation Protocol,
and that's fine. Part of what we're trying
to do here is determine more used cases so
we can draw that line of what is required
and what is not required. So, from one example
on that, there is operational transform. So
clearly, having consistency between one wave
of server and another wave of server, the
UT algorithm used to be the same. But, I don't
know who's remembering the way that Spelly
and Linky work inside Google Wave of product
but those are agents that are just features
we've decided to build for Google Wave users.
But clearly, having the same spell correction
is not required by our Wave providers. So
these are kinds of things that as we get more
used cases, we can figure out exactly what
are those lines are. Those two examples are
fairly straightforward. They are clearly ones
that are less straightforward. So, the other
point of Wave Federation is it's always been
the design so that you can have--so that the
Wave Feder can have complete control. So there's
a Wave itself is a hosted concept. And Jochen
will get a lot more into this. But there's
a concept of sort of local and foreign users.
And this ends up boiling down to being much
similar to SMTP in the sense that if you're
only dealing with local users, all the data
stays there. And then from the open classification
perspective, you know, we published a draft
last year, we're continuing to improve it
with input from the community as the used
cases come up. So, where we from so far, so
we--last year we published these protocols
in whitepapers. And then also in July, we
shipped FedOne. And FedOne is the sort of
naïve, "hello world" client server that then
federates over to other Wave providers. And
so, the idea there was to just encourage people
to prototype and play around with the protocol.
However, we didn't get how to port live and
so, little bit later on, I think it was run
on November, we opened up the Federation port
sort of experimentally on Wave Sandbox to
really let people take their FedOne instances,
instead to just talking to each other, they
can talk to Wave Sandbox. And so, they can
use the Google Wave Client and talk over to
FedOne. So today, we're working really hard
to open source more code. So we're deep in
the middle of working to wrap up open sourcing
nearly 100,000 lines more of code. And the
point there is it actually includes a fairly
significant trunk of our client. So the Rich
Text Editor, you may of heard about this in
a keynote, the Rich Text Editor is one of
the more difficult pieces to build because
of the cross-browser and firisys (ph) of that
about nature. And the idea would be to wrap
that editor in a very, very, very simple Wave
Client such that you can then have an open
source stack from the browser all the way
down to the server at the bottom and then
federate that over to Wave Sandbox. So this
is definitely a work in progress but we're
just telling you, give you the latest basically.
So to look at where we've come from a slightly
different angle, the set of Wave providers
that have sort of popped up in the various
community projects, and companies that are
getting involved. So certainly Novell Pulse
towards the end of the year, last year came
out and started sort of working with the Wave
Federation in Protocol. And there's QWave
which is a C++ client. PyGoWave actually started
as a gadget development toolkit but its turn
into more of a federated provider. So it's
interesting to see the evolution there. Ruby
on Sails, what it comes down to is sort of
like whatever language you like, there's probably
a product out there that you could probably
play with. ARWave is actually more, more of
a domain's specific use for the federation
protocol for augmented reality. But today,
as you may have heard about the keynote, SAP
StreamWork is also getting involved with the
Wave Federation Protocol to let users of one
system work with users on Google Wave and
other systems. And then, there's also ProcessOne,
is working on OneWave. And their--both all
these companies are demoing in a Wave Developer
Sandbox as well. So, that's the highlight
of the background. Where we're headed, there
are really three points; improving the specs.
Improving those specs such that we're able
to ship the wave of protocol federation port
open on googlewave.com and then building a
production quality reference implementation.
The idea is that maybe they should keep improving
on FedOne, the code we're working to open
source right now, as well as the next stage
such that you can really get out there and
have a production quality reference open source
implementation. And with that, I'd like to
bring up Jochen to go deeper into the Federation
architecture.
>> BECKMANN: Right, thanks Dan. Hi, everyone.
I'll give you a brief overview of architecture.
Hopefully, some of you would have already
looked at the wave protocol website, maybe
know some of these concepts better. But bear
with me, I'll try and get to this quickly.
So, are you familiar with the regular client
view? And what you generally call a wave is
basically the Wave panel with sometimes private
replies if you ever created private replies
being in lined. Now, conceptually, waves are
actually sets of wavelets. And a wavelet is
basically an XML or sets of XML documents
that have separate participant lists. So you'll
see here, for example, one wavelet has a separate
participant list from the private reply here.
And wavelets are composed entirely of operations.
So the history of the wavelet consists of
series of operations. And these operations
are packaged together in an envelope which
we use for transmitting between servers and
client-in server, which we call Deltas. And
operations are given a version number. So
Deltas span a series of versions. And as part
of the client-server protocol is the negotiation
of each client state. And these version numbers
allow you to determine a way to apply a Delta.
And the wave is the unit of access control
and concurrency control. Concurrency control
meaning that whenever you make a change to
a wavelet that can only happen concurrent
or automatically on one wavelet. So you cannot
expand multiple wavelets. And a Delta is authored
by one of the participants on that wavelet.
And here, I'll show you this pictorially by
having the participant in the tip of the Delta.
So we have a quick look at interactions between
different clients and the Wave server. Each
wave is owned by one wave server only. And
that wave server's the authority over at the
history of Delta applications to that wavelet.
And here we have three Web Clients. What you
see here in red is the two left Web Clients
trying to apply Deltas to a wavelet and the
wave server determines in which order they
are to be applied. And the dotted line shows
the acknowledgment coming back from the wave
server where the clients have attempted a
submission, we call them submit. And here
we have an acknowledgement for that submit
for the client on the left, it gets version
number 1. The client in the middle will get
version number 6 because there are 5 operations
and the first Delta that got applied. At this
time, you'll see the green arrows which are
updates, which I'll send to you all listening
clients. So the client on the far right gets
the Deltas simply streamed and the ones on
the left, they get the Deltas that, updates
that where not issued by that client. Both
clients are responsible, both clients and
servers are responsible for doing operation
of transformation. And if you want to see
more of the details of how the operational
transformation and concurrency control works
there's a link here at the bottom of the slide
to a talk that we've published last year which
will go into the nitty-gritty detail. Hopefully,
it'll be interesting. So next I'll give you
an overview of the federated case. Here we've
got two Web Clients. The ones on the left
are production Web Clients. And the simple
client on the right is the client that we've
released in Code-2, hopefully, today and tomorrow.
And this talks to the FedOne which is the
open source wave server that we released last
year. Between the two wave servers, we have
the Federation Protocol. And that protocol
deals with the transport of wavelets of Deltas.
And that allows the whole architecture to
work and to have a distributed network of
wave servers that talk to each other. If you're
here to find out about how you can extend
wave, there's basically five ways in which
you can extend wave. The first one, you probably
are quite familiar with, these gadgets and
these robots, they would do talks at Google
I/O this year. The first one has already happened,
that was this morning. The second talk is
tomorrow, gadgets and robots are basically
the gadgets to our client side or mostly client
side extensions, robots a combination of client
side and back-end. So those are separate APIs
and they've don't really have to do with Federation
at this point. The next way you might extend
wave as its stands is the open source client,
can be extended. So one could take the Editor
and the client-server protocol embedded in
your own client. And then, off you go and
hopefully, we'll see some interesting ones.
And I've already seen very, very different
implementations for how we see waves. So,
we hope that points the way of using wave
protocol as a basis for all kinds of platforms.
The FedOne server as we've released it has
a fledgling Agent API. This will hopefully
eventually converge to what we have in our
production service, the robot APIs as we call
them. And we've got a few agents already implemented
and this might be another way in which you
can interact in with wave. The same API can
be used to bolt on a gateway. So this gateway
would be translating between your system,
whatever your back-end system is, and the
FedOne Wave server. And something similar
would be to embed the entire wave server as
we've release it in your own system. And in
both of these two cases, you want to make
sure that whatever object you're presenting,
usually documents and changes to those documents,
map fairly cleanly to the operation of transformation
model. So you've got operations modifying
wavelets and that you can express whatever
these objects are that you're modifying in
the paradigm move waves and wavelets. Right,
and with that, I'll hand it over to J.D.
>> ZAMFIRESCU: Thanks. So, we're super excited
today to be announcing the open sourcing of
a bunch of new components of Google Wave,
mostly on the client side. We've got a Rich
Text Editor which Dan mentioned earlier, is
the actual editor that we use on our client.
We've got more model code. We'd previously
released a sort of stripped down version of
the model that we used in FedOne. And we've
expanded on that significantly and I'll talk
about that a little bit. We have a concurrency
control stack which implements some model
interfaces in such a way that there are changes
that are propagated into the server. And also
transform operations against each other so
that the client remains consistent in the
face of intervening operations from the server.
And finally, we have a WebSocket JSON protocol
that we released a couple of weeks ago and
are fleshing out today. And we hope we'll
be pushing into our repository later, later
today. So just a brief overview, the Wave
model consists of several different components.
There's a document model which contains its
several representations of an actual document.
As you may know our documents are sort of
canonically represented by XML and some of
them have constraints on them, things like
blips in the conversation model if you're
familiar. We also have a complete conversation
model that builds on top of that. We have
more wavelet and blip interfaces and implementations.
We have more operations on documents and waves.
Operations like add participant, manipulations
of blip, changing of content, that kind of
thing. Also, we have a concurrency control
stack. Now, this in addition to having channels
that communicate with the actual wave servers,
they also have a client implementation for
flow controls. This is a component that restricts
the number of operations you can send. It
also allows incoming operations to be transformed
against outgoing operations that everything
stays in sync. It also implements Wave interfaces
to help you actually interface with our wave
server for FedOne, and finally, the Rich Text
Editor, which I won't be talking too much
about today. So just to give a little overview
of the model, the main component here is the
WaveView which consists of several different
wavelet data instances, each of those contain
several blips. They're interact with concurrency
control by receiving operations that change
them and they send events back to concurrency
control which then packages them in Deltas
since sends them to and from the wave server.
Concurrency control has some model component
which is the part that actually does the transformations
and it sends operations through a multiplexer,
through a stacklet and a few other components
before actually sending Deltas down to the
server. So, just to give a little bit of an
example, here's how to create a wave. So if
you've got your editor hook up to a Wave manager
and concurrency control connected to a wave
server, and we've got an implementation of
this that we would be pushing out later today
or tomorrow. To create, you create a new editor
by sending a create request, the wave server
replies to that create request and the concurrency
control creates a new wavelet, a new blip,
a new editor from the Wave manager and the
Editor then hooks up its document to the document
that's generated by the concurrency control
stack. And then, from that point on, edits
to the Editor will flow through the content
document and down through concurrency control,
whether buffered if necessary, and transformed
and then down into the wave server. Yes. And
the wave serve itself then communicates with
other wave servers if necessary as Jochen
will tell us about.
>> BECKMANN: All right. In federation protocol
as we said is a server-to-server protocol.
It's designed as such. So some people have
tried using it as a client-server protocol,
I don't recommend that. That's what client-server
protocol is for. And fortunately, we'll be
releasing that code, so that's good. It allows
you to run your own wave service. As I pointed
out, you can even, you know, roll your own
extended wave, the wave technology, to whatever
you intend using it for, and we'll see some
great demos for that later today. The protocol
spec that we released last year is available
at waveprotocol.org. So hopefully, some of
you will have a look there, there's some whitepapers,
some really good contributions by other developers
for how the nitty-gritty of this operation
in transformation and Federation works, so
please have a look. The protocol is based
on XMPP. We released it last year in July.
And the operation in transformation and concurrency
control that we used for the Federation protocol
and in the server that we released, and in
the client that we're releasing, is the same
as what we have in production. And there are
some interesting optimizations that we made
to make it particularly suited to low-latency
updates. So, you know, when you see concurrent
editing and things like that, we've optimized
it. So there are some features which are quite
interesting like commit messages, two-face
commits things like that. That's--we won't
be going into too much detail today but it's
something that you might want to keep in mind.
All right. So, let's give it--let's have a
quick walkthrough to an example, to give you
a feel for what a protocol looks like. Again,
we won't have time to do a deep dive but I
hope this will be sufficient. Here we've got
one wavelet. You might be able to read here
the wavelet ID which is in the top here. And
the wavelet ID contains a domain name. And
that domain name determines which wave server
owns this wavelet. So in this case, it's the
FedOne Wave server on the right, and that
is because it's the IniTech Corp Wave server,
and they speak to their respective clients.
So we've got on the right here the Simple
Client, and on the left, our production client.
Both clients have modified the wave and so
the state here is both the clients have modified
the wavelet by adding a participant. They've
added different participants, so Anthony here
on the left and public on the right. And they've
submitted Deltas to their respective wave
service and the next step will be to see what
happens. So, the wave server on the left is
proxying wave server. It's--we call it our
Remote Wave server because it doesn't own
the wavelet. The wavelet on the right here
is the Authorative Wavelet because it lives
on the IniTech Corp Wave server. Therefore,
what the wave server on the left does is merely
forwards that Delta to the owning wave server.
And what's interesting about the Federation
protocol is we've build some security features
into it. So, it's signed here with X.509 signature
and by the owning or by the domain that has
a client making those changes. So in this
case, the serve for echowave.com is used for
signing. The Federation protocol also has
what we call the history hash, which is a
SHA256 running hash over all the Deltas that
went into the wavelet. So at any point you
can verify the state and the history, and
that all the wave servers agree about what
that history is. And it's actually also used
for authentication, so if you look at the
detailed protocol spec, you'll hopefully find
this quite exciting because when we first
pitched this, people thought it's fantastic
because an email and many other communications,
this sort of stuff was not built in. So our
security folks were really thrilled. All right,
so, on the right-hand side, we've got a Delta
that could applied, this is adding the public
participant. And this got immediately applied,
so you can see the Authoritative Wave down
here has that participant added. That Delta
is also assigned and it's forwarded to anyone,
any of the wave service that are interested,
so in this case, this wave server because
there is a participant here on that wavelet
that is from the echo wave domain. And it
so happens, I just drew some other wave server
that might be listening. And you might also
note that the wavelet on the left here, which
is the copy wavelet, has not changed because
this Delta has not been applied yet. And this
Delta is only applied by this server and not
by this server, so nothing has changed on
the left. Finally, this--the Delta that came
from the echo wave server got applied by the
IniTech Wave server the one on the right.
And it's been updated here and the Delta is
echoed back to this wave server, and it also
applied the previous Delta so that's Delta
is updated. And the clients all received the
updates as for the client-server protocol
that I showed you earlier. And importantly,
this acknowledgment, which was an acknowledgment
for the submit that we saw here, so this was
the submit and this is acknowledgment for
that submit, which is forwarded by this wave
server again acting as a proxy and is forwarded
to that client. All right, so, there's 4 basic
messages in the federation protocol, three
of which--or two of which I, you know, explained
which are submits and updates. The two other
important ones are history request and response,
which is if a wave server receives a Delta
at a version that is not version 0 and it
hasn't seen anything about this wavelet before,
it can turn around to the hosting wave server
and request the history from, in a version
range. To do that, it needs to furnish the
history of the request which is the authentication
mechanism I mentioned earlier. And it will
then be furnished with those Deltas that can
be applied, and hopefully the wave server
will be able to apply the Delta that have
received because of now has the full history
of that wavelet. Find an information request
and response is related to the signing that
I've mentioned earlier, where a certificate
can be requested from the wave server that
signed the Delta. The wave server that host
the wavelet has to keep all the certificates
for the wavelet that it has authority over
and these certificates are collected when
other wave service submit Deltas to it. And
this so for the other wave service to go away,
anyone can still verify that those Deltas
were authored by the domains that they claim
to be. So finally what do we still need in
the Federation protocol to make it match what
we have in production? Firstly, the protocol
is a push protocol. We currently don't have
a mechanism by which you do reliable delivery,
which means if you lose updates and wavelets
go dead there's no periodic attempt to contact
remote wave servers and tell them that there
might be something interesting for them, so
we're hoping to add that very soon. And we
also have federated attachments; we have the
spec out there or a whitepaper which will
allow you to have the attachments shared between
the servers. So currently we have that obviously
in the production client and the production
wave server, and once we can share that over
the federated protocol, we'll have full support
in Federation there. Groups, federated groups,
we have a whitepaper that is part of the access
control whitepaper on the site. We have a
fairly good idea of how that's implemented
and hopefully, we'll be implementing that
in the coming months. And finally, federated
presents, we have some designs on that and
hopefully, you'll see that in the next few
months as well. So for all of these forthcoming
attractions, we will be trying to put specs
out on the protocol Google group, that's been
a very good source of discussion and input
from people in the community, practically
XMPP folks who in some cases know more than
us wave guys about the ins and outs and some
of the paradigm of how to do things in XMPP
have. So that will be quite cool to hear back
from the community on that. So more documentation
on the federation protocol, on the protocol
side; the code lives on Google Code. There's
some great contributions by some folks like
Anthony Watkins, James Purser and Bryce that
we posted on further reading. And there's
other stuff on the, on the Google group so
please have a look. And, yeah, hopefully,
we'll federating with you before long. Cool.
And with that, J.D.
>> ZAMFIRESCU: Thanks. So one final thing
that we're going to talk a little bit about
before we do a little few demos is our client-server
protocol that we recently released. Now as
Jochen mentioned the Federation protocol is
relatively similar to the production client-server
protocol that we use. Well, this client-server
protocol that we released recently is also
very similar to that Federation protocol and
that you can think of it as a little bit of
a stripped down version, a slightly less functionalities,
slightly less functionality is needed. So
it's a protocol for receiving and submitting
changes on a particular wavelet. And it uses,
the one that we're releasing today, uses a
web socket transport with JSON encoded protobuffer-style
messages. And all I mean by protobuffer-style
messages is that they're actually just keyed
by numbers instead of typical JSON style where
you string key names. So to send an update
from the client to the server, the client
simply combines its outstanding operations
into a protocol wavelet Deltas. Puts that
Deltas into a protocol submit request and
sends it to the server. The server simply
replies with the protocol submit response
that indicates how many of the operations
it sent were applied and whether there was
any error. Receiving updates is slightly more
complicated. You send a protocol open request
with the wave id that you're looking for.
Now remember, wave id consists of multiple
wavelets so you can also specify a prefix
for all the wavelets that you're interested
in. So if you're only interested in a particular
wavelet you can specify the given prefix and
only get those, the ones that match and to
assist with. In the case where the connection
drops, were you can--the client can also send
a list of known snapshot versions. So for
every wavelet id that it already has on the
client, they can send the most recent version
that it seems from the server and then the
server will respond only with changes that
have happened since that point. This is to
prevent the server from needing to resend
a whole large amount of data. So the client
then receives a protocol wavelet update which
contains snapshots for any wavelets that already
exists in the Wave. And then beyond that it
receives updates Deltas for any changes to
those waves subsequent--to those wavelets
subsequent to the request, to the snapshots.
So to do a little bit of a timeline view,
you send a protocol open request, you receive
a snapshot back, you receive a marker indicating
the snapshots are done and then you receive
a series of Deltas with changes. Okay. So
now we are hoping to do a few demos. So I'll
start this off with a demo of the client-server
protocol that we've been working on. So if
I can get this working, let's see. So over
on the left I've got Wave Sandbox which presumably
some of you at least are familiar with here.
Yes, thank you. Ta-dah! So now let's see if
I can get this on the left. Let's try something
different. Okay, so we have a Googler in New
York under Hyatt who is a very big e-max enthusiast
and he graciously wrote a plug-in for e-max,
or an extension for e-max that actually receives
updates live. So if this is still connected.
You'll see that it's a little slower having
some network connectivity problems but hopefully
this will actually propagate all the way through.
Well, maybe not. Ah, yeah. So it's possible
that...
>> We blame the network.
>> ZAMFIRESCU: We blame the network. Well,
this is working good here, I promise. We were
also hoping to show you a demo of our simple
web client which unfortunately, despite many
long hours in same contributions by Bob Vawter
and Anthony Baxter, well, we cannot show you.
But this is code that we will be pushing live.
Where by live, I mean into our open source
repository at waveprotocol.org very, very
soon, as soon as we iron out these few last
bugs, and it is very exciting. So if you are
a developer and you are interested in having
your own Wave client you can use our, sort
of, simple Wave client to see how to hook
up to various components of the Editor and
the CC stack and all that together to actually
get a functional set-up done once we figure
out how to do that as well. I'm just kidding.
Yes, so with that I'll pass it on to some
Federation demos. Thanks.
>> I'm hoping for some better luck.
>> PETERSON: Alrighty. So we going to do some
split screen here. As Rob Horne, our product
manager--product owner on SAP StreamWork.
>> HORNE: Hello everyone. We're really excited
about this. We're going to be showing you
our new free product. And maybe you can sign-up
for today, for SAP StreamWork. And it's a
tool to help you make decisions in your everyday
work. So I'll be kind of hiding back here
and I'm going to--great, you can see me there.
>> PETERSON: That's great.
>> HORNE: So I have SAP StreamWork over here,
we've got Google Wave over here. And when
I create a new activity, we're not going to
go too much into too much storyline. But I'm
actually creating a new activity for the demo
here. And--oops! That was a brick. Okay, so
I'm going to quickly add a--are we all right
over there?
>> Just a second.
>> PETERSON: Macintosh is a new [INDISTINCT].
>> HORNE: While they're figuring that out,
I'm going to--so the activity purpose we would
put in here, I would say "Hey, Dan we need
to work on this together." Okay. So in StreamWork
you can invite anyone into a decision activity
whether in your organization or not. In here
I'm going to go ahead and have Dan and he
happens to be a Wave Sandbox user. So instead,
of him coming in and working in the activity
inside the StreamWork which would usually
what would happen. He should see, hopefully,
something in his Wave inbox and says, "Hey,
there's an activity and we want to work on
it together." Okay.
>> PETERSON: So glad I didn't open that.
>> HORNE: Well, before he goes crazy. I'm
just going to add a comment here and say,
"Can you help me with this?"
>> PETERSON: So one thing to point out there
is you'll notice that that did not stream
in character by character. And other thing
to point out is that previously we have talked
about draft mode when we're creating blips
in doing entries in Google Wave. You can,
sort of, think about this as, as if it shows
to implement auto draft mode for blip creation
whereas we chose the other Wave for now. Clearly,
draft mode is something we want to have in
Google Wave, but we haven't done it yet. But
this again shows differences that still work
on protocol.
>> HORNE: Now I actually happened to be logged
in as Joseph. Who's the developer who made
all this happen so that's not me but are always
me. So Dan's going to comment back here and
you can see it, if you can see it on my side
he actually is coming in character by character.
So we're really excited about that. And so
I'll just ask Dan and say, "Can you go back
into the blip where I say, 'Hey Dan, can you
go and edit some of the content of that?'
So we can start to work on this document or
whatever it is that we are working out together."
And you should see on my screen sometimes
it's character by character really fast and
sometimes it's--Oh, there he is! Maybe a bit
of a jumpy there. So what we're really working
together here, he's--we've made some comments
to each other back and forth. He's added the
document; you can imagine this was an important
document about our partnership. But we're
not going to get in to that too much right
now. Now in SAP StreamWork we provide you
with the set of tools to help you get your
work done. And in here I'm going to go in
to the deciding category and we happen to
have a very simple tool which we all use pro-cons
on a few options. I'm going to add that, very
much likely you would see in a widget or gadget
in Wave. And I'm just going to quickly type
in option one enter...
>> PETERSON: And you'll see as Rob is typing
his options in, they show up on Wave Sandbox
as well, using Federation as well as the similar
specs with guided APIs.
>> HORNE: Okay. So Dan notices, "Hey, you
forgot option three." So he's going to go
quickly add that in. Enter.
>> PETERSON: And then we can go ahead and
just, you know, add cons and add pros and
they will work just fine.
>> HORNE: Okay. So I'm not fan of option three.
I did the one thing out, it's not so silly.
Okay. Okay. And you should see it coming.
>> PETERSON: Indeed.
>> HORNE: Okay. And we're just getting a little
bit off here. Oh, it's actually just come
in.
>> PETERSON: Here we go. Yes.
>> HORNE: So forgive the slowness of the updating,
a little bit of network issues we're having
here. But you see them coming through and
the nice thing is, is his attributing that
change to Joseph, or me, and I can see those
come through as well, so.
>> PETERSON: Yeah. The idea here is that while
a Wave is a very interesting concept, a gadget
is a pretty important piece to it, because
text is interesting. But having things like
maps or things like pro-con tables either
written by the provider or written by third-party
developers are very important, instead of
having a similar set of gadget APIs that still
didn't federate across the various Wave writers
is very quite useful.
>> HORNE: Right. So I'm just going to add
a comment here quickly and say, "Let's go
with option two." And we're having now a conversation
about all the feedback we got in it, it comes
in as an indented blip. So this is a POC that
we're really excited to work on. That really
shows that we want to enable this kind of
communication to help get work done. SAP StreamWorks
really focuses on specific thing around getting
decisions done and helping you have the right
tools that we think is needed to get that
done. And we build in a lot of security in
different things that you only want in the
enterprise and we can invite all those Wave
people in there.
>> PETERSON: Yeah. So we get some more demos
up our sleeves. Thank you. This is David LaPalomento
from Novell.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Yes, hi. I am David LaPalomento.
I am a lead developer for the front end of
Novell Pulse, which maybe you heard about,
but it's a next generation social messaging
product that we're developing in Novell right
now. And basically, one of the primary goals
of Novell Pulse when we get started was to
let you instantly communicate with people
anywhere, whether, you know, they're your
friends or people in your team at work, in
the different business unit or in another
corporation or organization. So
it was natural fit to adopt the Wave protocol
and allow us, not only to do that sort of
real time collaboration with Pulse, other
Pulse users, but also do that with other Wave
protocol providers like we got google.com
or StreamWorks. So over here on the left for
you guys we got the home screen for Novell
Pulse and on the far left hand side of that
you'll going to see our navigation panel.
That's basically all the people in groups
that you're following. So this is other Pulse
users and groups that are in the system. You
build those up and then on the right hand
side that's basically an aggregation of all
the communications, all the Waves that you've
had with those individuals and things that
they've posted to their feeds for the public
consumption or direct communication that you've
had with them. So Dan if you can jump into
Wave real quick.
>> PETERSON: Sure.
>> LAPALOMENTO: We can actually send the message
from Wave today and it should appear--assuming
that our network traffic works well almost
spontaneously over on Pulse.
>> PETERSON: And which was easy. You want
to send it to...
>> LAPALOMENTO: K. Childs I believe we got.
Karl Childs.
>> PETERSON: Add into my contacts. Go ahead
and throw him on the Wave. And so what's going
on now is that as similar to what Jochen's
architecture earlier. The advertent operation
should be being sent from the local wavelet
here over there but not quite. Are you okay
Childs?
>> LAPALOMENTO: I am and we're not--having
troubles. Let's see. Let's try this again
real quick. Sorry about that.
>> PETERSON: [INDISTINCT] are you going to
Wave?
>> LAPALOMENTO: Okay. So...
>> PETERSON: There she is.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Little, little boy there.
But anyways, that's the message that Dan did.
Yeah, thank you. All right. And so in Pulse
we can immediately come in here and start
replying. So we're going to say, "Hi, Dan
how's the conference?" And hopefully much
quicker this time. He should see it over there.
Oh, man, we are just dying with this network,
huh? There he goes. All right, so.
>> PETERSON: There you go.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Like magic.
>> PETERSON: Much better.
>> LAPALOMENTO: It shows up. So that's great.
And it, you know, helps breakdown the barriers
between, you know, the two projects. You can
have people in Wave that you communicate or
any Wave server that you guys develop in the
future. It should all just work that simply.
>> PETERSON: So my response is going in over
there.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Yes, in write reply. So now
actually we can also do the real time editing
as well. So if I go over here in Pulse and
click edit, I can go ahead and say "It's going
great." And hopefully over in Wave, in not
too long, we should see that come across.
Okay. Well, that's a good start.
>> PETERSON: Hi.
>> LAPALOMENTO: It's like we're running on
a 288 modem here.
>> PETERSON: You know, so I mentioned before
advances in broadband technology that they
are out there, I promise.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Yes. So at some point that
will come across and basically, Dan should
be able to do the same and we would see it
over on the left hand side. Well...
>> PETERSON: I think this Wave may have gotten
turbulent along the way.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Okay.
>> PETERSON: Perhaps.
>> LAPALOMENTO: So we can try something really
dangerous right now which is a...
>> PETERSON: I suppose, I mean they're all
there, they like to see it. So we probably
should give it at a shot. Yeah.
>> HORNE: So Dan told me a couple of days,
two days back, he said "Hey, Novell's going
to be on stage too. It's all right. Everything's
great" and I said "Yes, that's awesome." And
then we--I was talking to Joseph and said
"Hey, why won't we try a three-way Wave?"
So we're going to just be able to get crazy
and I'm going to start an activity off. I'm
going to invite the guys and we're going to
see if we get this to work now. Our probability
of success with the network could be crazy
but let's just...
>> PETERSON: Well, I mean the whole point
here is that's its many Wave providers not
just, you know, two, or two. So let's give
it a shot.
>> HORNE: Okay. Okay, there's something crazy.
Okay. Oh, I'll just got to invite you guys,
that's right. So I'm going to invite you guys.
K. Childs and Dan. Okay.
>> PETERSON: So I got Novell here with Sandbox.
>> HORNE: And we head back to the home screen.
>> PETERSON: Okay.
>> HORNE: I believe will see it there as well.
Hey, it's well done.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Here we go.
>> PETERSON: Indeed, so visiting the Wave
in Pulse. Now I blip.
>> HORNE: Yes. So we're typing our reply right
here in Pulse making the new blip.
>> PETERSON: I'm blip there. So and that's
part one and now over the--over there.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Great. No, you're going to
edit that.
>> PETERSON: I'm going to edit this.
>> HORNE: So I can see it online. And maybe,
no, it will be asking too much to see it over
here. Yes.
>> PETERSON: There we go. A little more delay
than we would like but, you know, it's getting
there.
>> HORNE: Next, last crazy thing. See if we
can get these gadgets. Okay.
>> LAPALOMENTO: I mean we get text-less few
gadgets.
>> HORNE: Here's option one.
>> PETERSON: There we go.
>> HORNE: So okay. So...
>> PETERSON: And Pulse.
>> LAPALOMENTO: And Pulse.
>> PETERSON: All three.
>> HORNE: So we can go and add some things
but I think we're getting to that.
>> PETERSON: Anyway, we don't kind to need
to go and hear about it.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Yes.
>> PETERSON: I mean its great to see a gadget
added from--as StreamWork show both on Pulse
and the Wave Sandbox and that, sort of, the
overall direction of where we're headed here.
So I mean, I thank you all for your time listening
to the presentation, various demos and some
of the quirks involves. But, you know, we're
working really hard to sort of build those
community, get more Wave writers involved,
get more use cases about how the protocol
can work, a lot of specs and a lot of code
coming up on waveprotocol.org momentarily.
And have some time for questions now at the
end if people have them. We'll also jump over
to moderator J.D. and Jochen here might come
back up. Questions at the mics if there are
any. Yes, please. J.D. can you be the moderator?
>> Within your demos where you're doing federation
between...
>> PETERSON: Bring the [INDISTINCT] please.
>> In your demos when you're doing this testing
between federated servers had you had enough
time to understand programmatically what latency...
>> PETERSON: [INDISTINCT] do that.
>> ...is required as you add additional Wave
servers to values of N?
>> BEKMANN: In short, probably no. We haven't
done extensive testing. The whole way in which
the client-server protocol is designed is
so that it's able to cope with latencies,
disconnects. And all it really means is clients
will optimistically modify waves locally and
the Wave server sync up in the back and basically
what you'll see is what you just saw. The
experience degrades but it should all function.
It just means that things trickle in and you
guys might have experience the bad network
connectivity we have from ourselves. And,
yes, if we can--if we confederate on the conditions
like this I think we're doing pretty well.
>> PETERSON: Please, yes.
>> I was wondering I see on the Novell Pulse,
I see an insert attachment, now I know we
can't--one of the things that says it wasn't
done yet was federated attachments.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Yes.
>> What about the attachment for just in,
just for Novell Pulse? Just for Novell Pulse
users. Does that mean that it's, it can't
be federated across or it is not in the open
source client yet for having attachments?
>> BEKMANN: Well, I'm sure it works in Pulse
but it doesn't federate at this point and
the open source client does not do attachments
as of yet.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Yeah. But we were certainly
working together.
>> BEKMANN: Yes. It will come.
>> Pardon me, you implemented, you implemented
a way to do attachments for just Novell Pulse.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Yeah we did. So we have attachment
support today. And the idea is that we're
going to kind of, you know, we have a kind
of Federation gateway that seats inside of
our project and we will, you know, do the
translations. So that when the Federation
attachment of, you know, protocols all worked
out, we'll be extremely to cross and receiving
them back and all that fun stuff.
>> Okay.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Okay?
>> Okay. Thanks.
>> LAPALOMENTO: Good.
>> Hi. As you've seen it's sometimes quite
difficult to determine whether the person
that you're federating with is actually receiving
the updates that you're sending to them. So
you've mentioned that is going to be a guaranteed
delivery, kind of part of the protocol. So
will that include mechanisms that will determine
that I'm working on--as a provider, I'm working
my clients and this guy that I'm working with
is not receiving the messages.
>> BEKMANN: Yeah. So we have acknowledgement
mechanisms already in the protocol and that
should be sufficient to be able to do the
retransmits from both FedOne and the production
Wave servers. That's the only bit that's really
missing. Some of the error handling in the
FedOne Wave server is also not quite complete,
and that's the part that's kind of missing.
Once that's done it should be all good. It
should already be able to determine on the
Wave what is and what is not arriving. It's
just the retransmission that isn't working.
All of this is pretty much already part of
the spec, it's just not well implemented and
it's not thoroughly documented unfortunately,
but its coming.
>> PETERSON: Let me grab one question from
the moderator just because people were putting
some questions into the Wave. So the highest
voting question appears to be, "Will we be
able to use the current Google Wave user interface
with our private Wave servers?" And so this
gets back into the effort of our open sourcing
which is what were working on very hard around
open sourcing the Editor with the simple web
client around it and that, sort of, beginnings
of more client code. So getting the FedOne
prototype out there in the first page was
most important to be able to bring out more
federated providers and then moving on from,
sort of, the back-end code to getting the
model out there, let's us be able to open
source some of the client. And so that's what
we're starting with today and then more clients
will come as time moves on. So I think, yes
please. Oh, thank you.
>> So what happens when you have two clients
that evolve on the same, the same...
>> PETERSON: Operational transform?
>> No. How did I brought?
>> PETERSON: Sorry.
>> The same, no--or gadgets, thank you.
>> Two, when you have two clients and like
two different clients on two different servers
that don't evolve on the same gadgets, same
like Frontend plug-ins.
>> PETERSON: So I think you're saying...
>> I, so I have a way, I'm showing a way with
somebody and I create a chart for example
or something like that, and then that's not
implemented on another client.
>> PETERSON: Well, so the way that gadget
functionality works actually is, so long as
the Wave providers support gadgets that should
be the same set of APIs that are available.
And so by putting it into the Wave, the Wave
document is updated to have this links to
the HTML file that defines to the gadget.
And then it can be rendered on both sides.
>> Okay.
>> PETERSON: Yes?
>> Yes.
>> HORNE: Like for instance--you saw we use
the pro con there and like in our goal is
so that any gadgets that come through from
the Wave, because they're gadgets, we want
them to work in StreamWork. And that's kind
of one of the reasons why we want to do this
in so that we can take a lot of the tool in
that, in different gadgets that come, and
bring them into our environment and then we
move seamlessly back and forth. That's kind
of one of the goals that were hoping to, and
that we would inherit that by working the
gadgets better.
>> PETERSON: Yes. So we're building along
lot of the work from open sourcing here with
infrastructure like Apache Shindig which lets
people get their own gadget server up and
running. And so as long as we all have a gadget
server, it doesn't have to be Shindig, but
as long as we have something that is, that
supports our open sourcing gadget specification
then it will all just work. Yeah. I want to
grab--sorry, please go ahead now.
>> Will you cover pre-configured versions?
So I can just take it and almost into the--implement
it on my web server on my web page?
>> PETERSON: Sorry. I didn't quite catch the
question. Maybe Jochen.
>> BEKMANN: Sir, I think--sir, did you asked
whether you can take the code that we're about
to release and run it on your web server?
>> Basically.
>> PETERSON: Yes. Yes.
>> BEKMANN: Pretty much. I'm not sure about
how you'd hook it into your web server but...
>> PETERSON: Yeah.
>> BEKMANN: Runs with J.D. and yeah, you can
take it and put it up on your site.
>> ZAMFIRESCU: I mean you can definitely,
if you have a shared hosting or something
like that you'll be able to run it there.
You'll need certificates and so on if you
want to federate with Google Wave or with
StreamWork or for Pulse. But if you're not
just confederating--why you will not federate,
I don't know--but you can just run it on shared
hosting and it will serve an interface and
you can just use it directly to that with
other people that you work with and so on.
>> PETERSON: Speaking about the federation
crypto piece, but Jochen can do you want to
speak a little bit to why that's baked in
to the protocol?
>> BEKMANN: I was going to make a pick up
on the certificates that you mentioned. So
as I explained, you know, Deltas are assigned
for that. You need certificates issued by
some well-known CA, Certificate Authority,
and need DNS records set up for the XMPP side
of the federation protocol. It's a little
bit of a hoop to jump through but it allows
you to use a secure, you know, federation
protocol which will federate with all Wave
servers that support it. Once you got that
you're all good.
>> PETERSON: And the point there is for verification
so you can't spoof and...
>> BEKMANN: Yeah. So that does the security
features of the federation protocol.
>> PETERSON: So you know where the traffic
came from. It's all signed up.
>> BEKMANN: But having said that, when you're
testing locally you can disable those. There's
actually, in the start up script, there's
two flags. You disable it. You don't need
any search you can use self sign search. But
that will only work for your own test break,
it won't work against Wave Sandbox.
>> PETERSON: Yeah. So just for easier prototyping
you, yeah.
>> BEKMANN: That's right.
>> PETERSON: Do you have another question?
>> No. That's it.
>> PETERSON: Okay. If there are no more questions
we'll be hanging out front here and happy
to ask questions or answer questions one-on-one.
Maybe ask a couple in response but we'll see
what happens. So thank you again for coming.
>> BEKMANN: Thanks.